Oh welcome everybody to this this free
webinar on Epictetus a great stoic
philosopher and his views on choice and
character I think probably a lot of you
know me already from my videos but let
me introduce myself anyway I'm Gregory
Sadler I'm the president of reason i/o
which is a company devoted as it says in
the slogan down below to putting
philosophy into practice and this is
part of what we do I'm also the editor
of Stoicism today and online blog or
magazine which which focuses on modern
applications of stoicism and
understanding stoic figures it's part of
the same organization that puts on stoic
on the stoic on X's and a number of
other interesting things and my my
interest in epictetus and stoic
philosophers goes back to graduate
school I would say that I didn't take
them quite as seriously as a have
started to over the last five years as a
graduate student you know because I was
studying other things but I've long had
an interest in this particular topic of
character and how our choices end up
forming that so this is a one I've been
really looking forward to I think we're
finishing the Year Strong with this I
also do want to put in a word about my
patreon supporters this is a you know
this is essentially a free service and
it's being underwritten by those who
support me on patreon it's through their
generosity that I can afford to devote
the time to producing these sorts of
events and resources so I just wanted to
put in a little bit of gratitude about
about them so what we're going to do in
this is we're going to have a very brief
introduction I'm going to raise a few
interesting questions that hopefully
you'll have some clear idea about by the
end and then the main topics that we're
going to be discussing are stoic
philosophy and the three disciplines one
of which has to do with choice and then
is this Faculty of choice and how it is
that we actually modify it and use it in
the prime
now if that doesn't make a lot of sense
to you at this time that's perfectly
fine that's what the webinars for and
then we have 20 minutes reserved for
question-and-answer discussion open
conversation at the the end of the
webinar so here's a couple questions to
consider and you don't have to consider
these from a stoic perspective these are
much broader one is do we really have a
capacity to choose for ourselves our
choices free in any respect I think not
only in our own time but if you look
throughout history we find some people
asserting that our choices aren't in any
meaningful way free what does that do to
the whole notion of say character or
choice or or you know deciding for
ourselves another thing we want to think
about is well what impact do the choices
whether they're free or not that we make
have on who we are and what kind of
people we become and then a third thing
that intersects with that what does it
mean to have a good character is that
something actually good for us or is
that maybe something that society just
tells us we ought to have and mystics
have some very definite answers about
these sorts of matter so this this
webinar is the first we always do this
early in the week we have a free
45-minute webinar so it's going to
introduce you to some of epic Titus's
ideas bearing on choice and character
later on this week we have for those who
are interested in this intensive online
seminars going much deeper into these
ideas and adding some additional
discussions about you know how we
understand and change these things so
those are taking place on Saturday
December 16th from 10:00 a.m. to 12:00
p.m. 4 p.m. to 6 p.m. Central Time so if
you're interested in those you might
want to mark your calendar and go back
to your type forum link and register
otherwise just uh sit back and enjoy
what we've got and get ready to have
some discussion so the first topic I
wanted to bring up I didn't want to
assume that anybody already had a deep
background in stoic philosophy but I was
going to assume that Elise
people you know had heard of Stoicism so
here's some very basics about the Stoics
school it was a classical school of
virtue ethics which means that they hold
that virtue is the primary good for for
human beings and vice or you know the
opposite of virtue bad habits is is the
bad and you notice I've got this this
thing here about good bad and
indifferent so the Stoics differed from
some of the other schools of virtue
ethics like that of the Aristotelian 's
and saying that really when it came down
to it the only things that were
genuinely good and bad in themselves are
our states of character or our actions
or things that that come from us
everything else like wealth or health or
social esteem all those are what they
call indifference they don't have moral
value whether positive or negative in
themselves although they certainly can
be used the right way or wrong way and
that can conduce to something being good
or bad but they're not good or bad by
themselves the stomach's also have this
ideal of living in accordance with
nature and that's kind of a complicated
topic what I'm actually working on a
short book on at the moment but you can
say that in a nutshell what it means is
we should sort of conform ourselves to
the way that the universe is and we
should try to develop what it is that
our our nature is as rational beings the
stomachs also stressed as you see other
virtue ethicists doing the inter
relation between thoughts and feelings
and I think this is one reason why stoic
philosophy is so particularly useful in
the present because we have a lot of
other perspectives which tell us things
like well you know feelings can't be
evaluated just have them and you can't
control your feelings the Stoics lot no
there actually is a linkage between
thoughts and feelings and so you can see
this in in certain psychological
approaches like that of cognitive
behavior therapy or the entire cognitive
revolution which of course gets its rise
from stoicism the Stoics also focus on
making progress
towards happiness or eudaimonia not a
Latin in a fleeting state of happiness
but a lasting state of happiness or
doing well and freedom they laid a very
high stress on them so where does
epictetus fit in
we typically divide the stoah into an
early middle and late period and
unfortunately we have very little of
what the early and middle stoah wrote a
good portion of what we do have is
coming down to us through texts that are
not actually by Stoics like like cicero
who gives us you know for example pentia
says ideas on ethics in his on-duty and
it's really when it comes to the
literature that we have at present just
the late Stila that we possess and and
we may not even have all of that Seneca
and Moo Sonia's Rufus are coming earlier
in time than epictetus Musso Gnaeus was
of course Epictetus teacher in Rome and
there was some historical connection
Epictetus as owner because Epictetus was
a slave he actually worked for a Nero
who Seneca had worked for earlier before
Nero commanded him to kill himself and
then we have Marcus Aurelius you know
bringing up the rear and he's a Roman
Emperor who is actually read epic foetus
and and brings him up in his meditations
there's there's a interesting
distinction and it appears to have had
you know some sort of routing and how
stoicism was being to pull out and
thought about at the time of Epictetus
called the three disciplines and you can
find this discussed in his discourses
it's a doctrine that we find in
epictetus --is works but we don't find
it elsewhere explicitly in stoic
literature and as a side note I think a
lot of people tend to make a little bit
too much of this because they follow up
here odd those great books but but a
little bit speculative about these three
disciplines you know being correlated to
all these other things which which we
just don't see is the case
and so you see infographics with that
what we what we can actually say Apetit
teaches us is that there's a discipline
of desire and that has to do with not
just desires and aversions but also the
emotions understanding them reshaping
them a discipline of action which has to
do with choices and and refusals and
also with our duties and then the
discipline of assent which has to do
much more with the cognitive aspects of
things and he actually brings us up in
the context of saying too many people
want to jump you know leapfrog into the
discipline of ascent and that focus on
the other ones so where does choice fit
in here choice there's really three
different Greek terms or families of
terms that that get translated as choice
and they're all connected with each
other so there's this [ __ ] may which
also means impulse in in other thinkers
and it's the opposite to rejection so
choice and rejection deciding on
something and then doing it this fits
into the second discipline the
discipline of action there's also other
language used in epictetus --is work of
choice or choosing in FL EMA in the noun
and then felling in the verb this means
something like to select or for it to be
your will or your choice and then a
really key idea in Epictetus that is is
um it's not unique to him but but his
treatment of it is rather unique is the
Faculty of choice the pro raíces that in
which that in us that that chooses so
that's a really important idea so you
see choice is already a little
complicated so let's talk about this
Faculty of choice the pro races that I
brought up so the question that we can
ask well what is this and if you look at
translations English translations I
actually should go and sometimes look at
what what French you know common
translations they're probably Volante
for the most part or a German
translations are just for some
comparative stuff but in English we
usually translated as Faculty of choice
so the part of us that actually engages
in choosing or moral purpose and there's
a good reason why we call it moral
purpose it's also get a sense of being
something substantive something lasting
and I'm not really happy with these
sorts of translations but sometimes
people will use will or volition I think
there's good reasons to think that you
know the Faculty of will as we later see
it isn't quite exactly the same thing is
what epictetus is calling prior ASIS
there's a lot of good scholarship out
there on that in epictetus of stoic
psychology it's really the same thing as
two other things that he mentions one of
these is what he calls the ruling
faculty to hegemony cone that is you
know the thing that's in charge we might
call it the executive faculty and then
also there's what what he calls the
rational faculty to Logie code the one
that is thinking things out and the
reason why these can actually be the
same thing is because for the Stoics in
a rather complicated way that i'm not
going to try to explain here choosing
and cognition or thinking are not
radically separated from each other so
this is another reason why we don't
probably want to call this the will
because later thinkers would distinguish
between say the intellect and will now
another key a really important aspect to
this for epictetus the pro basis is the
core of the person in some passages he
actually says look you're not your flesh
you're not your possessions you are your
pro i races or rather not your private
oasis you are racist that is what you
are at your core at at the you know you
might say that the very fabric of your
your character or personality so this is
what the person is for better or for
worse and that makes it very important
for us to look at so let's talk about
choice Epictetus also makes a
distinction that i think some of you may
be familiar with we actually did a
session on this a couple months back
between what is in our control and
what's not in our control and what isn't
in our control our external things and
these things are determined by something
or someone other than ourselves so if we
take for example your reputation
you can certainly do things to screw up
your reputation and you can try to build
your reputation but whether or not your
reputation remains the same is very much
dependent on what other people choose to
do or think or or say and some of its
dependent on just you know the way
physical processes work out now
Epictetus talks about what's falling in
the scope of prior races what is under
it what is what is you might say its
business is what is in our control so
what does this mean he says that this
includes our thoughts and our judgments
you know opinions is another way to
translate judgment emotions these are in
our control these are a matter of the
pro races desires choices actions what
we assent to what it is that we we think
all of this is actually up to us in some
degree now you might ask then okay so
that's great what then determines the
per a racist because the pro races
controls all the other faculties of the
human being in some way I mentioned that
it's like the ruling faculty which is
essentially a synonym for it the end
epictetus is discourses and enchiridion
so all the other faculties that we have
all of the the capacities of our body of
our mind everything else is subject to
Pro a races of course you know the body
being something in the world there's
many things about it that you can't
really control
you know he's example of illness and
health but here's where it gets really
interesting Pro races also controls or
determines Pro a racist
so there's what we call reflexivity it
bears upon itself and it has freedom
this doesn't mean that it has total
freedom where it can like you know snap
its fingers and become something
radically different than than what it is
we're going to talk about that in just
just a few minutes but it does have a
degree of freedom that we often don't
take account of we forget about or
sometimes we even hide from ourselves
especially when we're doing things that
we know we should do we blame it on
things outside of our control so
Epictetus says that when something else
seems to be determining the prior ASIS
or to use one of his favorite words
impeding it to literally put fetters
upon it
it's becomes pry raices has allowed that
other thing to be decisive now if this
is starting to sound very familiar to
you but you haven't studied stoic
philosophy but you have studied
existentialist thought you may in fact
see some parallels here or if you're you
know reading somebody like Descartes
Descartes says some similar things as
well
Descartes is influenced by the Stoics
there's there's a number of other
thinkers and movements that take a
similar stance towards what they call
the will pray racist in this case is
what what Epictetus is focusing on and
he tells us that that the only thing
that can really rule or govern or
determine pricess is prior basis and
when it becomes corrupted its processes
own fault now you know this is loss so
if you don't want to say well my pro a
racist made me do it because you are
your prices so there's a few things
though that that human choice can't
actually do there are some limitations
on it it can't successfully choose the
nature of things to be other than they
are so for example if you tell yourself
stories about how you can make you know
bad choices day in day out and it's not
going to really make you into a bad
person no you will become a bad person
and you're choosing to tell yourself
essentially a lie about the way things
work you just by choosing that you're
not going to make things different
Epictetus even says you know the gods
themselves and they made human beings
they unfortunately they had to you know
give us parts that didn't you know they
were not as amenable like the body to
our you know our higher faculties and
they would have done it differently if
they could have so there's there's
something about the nature of things
that just is the way it is and we can't
we can choose to go along with it or we
can choose to fight against it
we also can't make things that are
outside of our control actually be in
our control and this is a lifelong
struggle for some of us even those who
are you know very steeped in and
practicing stoicism find themselves
falling into temptations to try to make
things that are outside of our control
actually be in our control and this is
really along the same lines you things
that are outside of your control
according to the Stoics just are that
way and your knack to change the nature
of reality the other thing that's really
important for what we're talking about
here is that we can't immediately change
the structure of our established
character and if you think about your
character in terms of prior races it's
not just what you've chosen it's how
your prior asus has chosen to shape
itself to direct itself to orient itself
and once that happens it's not as if you
can as I said snap your finger and you
know say okay I'm changing all of this
right now so let's talk about character
what are we what do we mean when we're
discussing character for the Stoics they
had some pretty clearly defined ideas
about good character and Epictetus fills
us out quite a bit he frames it
primarily in terms of having ones pry
races in accordance with nature a fully
developed human nature so what it is
that our human potential as rational
creatures would put forward and and he
doesn't think that many of us do in fact
realize this 100% but that doesn't mean
that we can't make progress towards it
so another way of making this a bit more
kind of create that the Stoics talked
about a lot was developing and acting in
accordance with the virtues and we'll
talk about those in just a minute
another thing that epictetus really
stresses but you also see this in you
know for example Cicero and Seneca
fulfilling duties involved in one's
roles and relationships and then finally
dealing with using is another way of
translating the Greek there of crisis
appearances are the things that
and impinge upon us the things that come
to come to us they're also translated as
impressions or you might even say
imaginations fantasy I external things
and emotions dealing with these things
well is part of what gives us good
character from the stoic perspective so
let's talk about the virtues the Stoics
did not come up with the cardinal
virtues Plato actually you know is the
one who formulates these in you know for
example the Republic in a few other
works he actually includes piety but
it's not quite clear if that's just
supposed to be part of justice or not
but these four virtues are viewed as
things that are rooted in the soul they
become part of who we are and each of
them has opposed vices as well and each
of them helps us fulfill what it is to
be a human being each of the feature
that makes us function well wisdom
teaches us what we ought to do helps us
to pursue truth for its own sake justice
which doesn't include only you know
following laws and fulfilling promises
but also includes benevolence for the
Stoics you know taking care of people
that is very important and in this
response to this social instinct that we
have as rational creatures courage which
could include battlefield courage but
also includes standing up to tyrants and
bullies and being able to stay firm in
our convictions being able to be as you
know it's not a word we use much in
these days but magnanimous in our great
soul that's part of courage and then
self-control you know being able to give
reason the the last just you know
decisive voice in what it is that we
ought to do instead of just following
our appetites or desires for bodily
pleasures or to avoid bodily pains these
are all important aspects of the stoic
life and then if you want to know more
about these I would read Cicero's on
duties he discusses these in great
detail now there's another one that
epictetus talks about a lot
he brings it up he doesn't actually talk
about virtue or the virtues quite as
much as the others because he uses prey
races instead but you know a virtue is a
particular way in which one's Pro races
is shaped the one that he probably talks
about the most is fidelity or pista s--
war that we also translate is faith you
know in in other contexts and this has
to do with something that is very
closely connected I think with justice
but perhaps maybe understood is a little
bit different than than just justice on
its own but this is what he means by
having a good character he also really
stresses on Duty's Duty is translating
the the latinum the Greek cafe con this
is a thing that the Stoics talked about
quite a bit and this falls under the
discipline of action what we want to do
right
the Stoics thought that many of our
roles and relationships even though
they're not chosen by us they give us
our duties and then we have choices
whether we're going to say fulfill our
duty or not or whether we're going to
fulfill it but we're going to roll our
eyes and and you know kind of cut
corners or things like that
right so we not only choose whether or
not we fulfill the duties but we also
choose our outlook and our motivations
so if you've got a parent for example
Epictetus has plenty of examples of
parents who do not measure up quite to
what they ought to be doing you have a
choice are you going to be a good child
to them or are you going to say well I'm
not getting what I want from mom and dad
so screw them I'll do whatever I want
that's your choice you actually have a
choice about that and that forms your
character so let's talk finally now
about the role of habit habit is is the
bridge you could say between choice and
character and this is something that not
only holds for epictetus not only holds
for the Stoics but holds for virtue
ethics in general this is this
centrality of habit
so let's talk about character is kind of
a starting point and I want to point
something out to you that
I certainly know from experience myself
and I think you could probably agree to
as well by the time that we start
thinking about our character we've
usually developed a character with its
whole range of habits they could be good
or they could be bad
in my case you know by the time I
started thinking about this sort of
thing I was doing it in part because I
wanted to work on problems with my
character and I think this may be
something many can relate to so we
already have desires and aversions and
they've already been shaped into into
particular you know directions you could
say we already have typical emotional
responses we already have patterns of
choices that we've made and we can also
think about beliefs or judgments that we
hold about important matters as being
part of these habits it's not merely
about what we do it's also about what we
think and one important aspect of this
what I think is not stressed enough but
but there's certainly plenty of room for
in Epictetus is the role that the
relationships we maintain he talks about
you know sometimes you actually have to
change who your friends are if you want
to improve morally but also the stories
that we tell the ways in which we look
at situations this is this relates to if
you've ever heard him say we can always
pick things up by one of two handles one
of the handles we can carry it the other
handle we can't that is about the
stories that we tell about what it is
that we're doing some stories are going
to make us bitter and resentful and are
going to make it impossible for us to
carry the things that we need to carry
other narratives are going to do the
opposite so here's a good question
you know the Stoics really liked this
guy Heraclitus we don't know that much
about and we don't really have any
writing strip we have fragments and
here's one of the most famous fragments
ethos on prople die moan and it's often
translated as character is destiny
there's other ways of translating it but
but that let that's good for the present
right character is destiny so what does
this mean does this mean that you know
we get our character and we're just kind
of stuck with it
so that you know however it happened the
way we were born the way we're raised
the people that we fell in with the
institutions that we participated in
we're just kind of stuck with that or
does this mean that these are both in
our control and affected by our choices
that we can change our character and
thereby we can change our destiny we can
change our fate we can change you know
if we want to play on the words we can
change whether we have an a diamond or a
deuce diamond good or bad spirit or not
so this is where habits become very
important Epictetus tells us that once
we have an established habit it's going
to guide our choices and actions and
emotions and thoughts often in a very
automatic way if we're not paying close
attention to it if we're not applying a
you know with the Stoics called Pro Sol
K which sometimes gets translated as
mindfulness or attentiveness then we're
liable just to follow along with the the
same way that we've always been doing
things so stoic philosophy can help us
to understand where we've been going
wrong right in these as a matter of fact
Epictetus likens his school to going to
the doctor's office and he says you know
you're probably not going to like it
here nobody goes in it's not like the
president right where our doctors visits
are sometimes not not so bad
nobody goes into the doctor's office
expecting it not to hurt he says so so
don't expect that to be the case going
into the Stoics school and he says it's
not reasonable to expect that we're
going to be able to simply choose a
different character once we have a
better perspective and you see a lot of
people doing this with not just with
stoicism but with personal development
and and applications of philosophy in
general they read some stoic philosophy
and they're like oh that's you know now
I understand how I ought to behave I'll
just do that and epictetus would say
it's not quite so easy as that if it
were it wouldn't actually need a
discipline of action so you know we can
think about it this way choices affect
our habits we have to make choices
repeatedly often again
the established grain in order to change
who we are in order to change the habits
so this is where we're using our per a
racist to change our Pro a racist right
we have to impose discipline upon
ourselves and as he says go over to the
other extreme he's got an example of a
ship that you know kind of tilts to one
side well you got to push it all the way
to the other side to get it to come back
and we often do have to change our
setting and companions you know he says
it at one point boy if you're going to
try to be a stoic but you're going to
hang around with all these these other
people who definitely are not into that
it's not really going to take you don't
have the capacity to do that it's you
know common human problem the other
thing that he stresses that's kind of a
cause for hope is any this is in the
enchiridion also in the discourses the
resources for responding more
appropriately to situations they are
within us we have those resources but
they have to be cultivated so when we
encounter situations where we might be
tempted say to you know make a fool of
ourselves in terms of you know our
sexuality and behavior well we have
temperance for that but we have to
decide to deploy it we have to decide to
take the the bit of it that we find
inside of ourselves and cling to it
almost like a shipwrecked you know
clinging to a board right and if we
don't do that if we don't make that
choice well no surprise if instead we do
something stupid and so in every
situation
Epictetus says we can remind ourselves
about that what we choose has a lasting
implication beyond that such situation
it's not just choosing for right now
we're choosing what we're going to be
like next week if I am struggling as I
often have in my life with anger and I
decide to apply the stoic remedy to it
it's not going to be easy but in making
it easier for myself the next time and
the next time in the next time if I only
think about this given situation right
now I can lose sight of the fact that if
I keep doing the same thing I'm actually
making that habit stronger and making
myself worse off
so now we have reached the time for
dedicated Question and Answer feel free
to unmute yourself and ask whatever
you'd like or if you want to use the
chat function I'll read your question
out loud and answer it so who wants to
go first
ah so Markos got a good question here to
what extent can we choose our
environment and circumstances according
to Epictetus so that's going to depend
on on you know who we are I would say
that if Epictetus were around in our
present he would say that there's
there's a good bit that's not in our
control you know how the economy
functions totally out of our control the
family that we we got you know dealt got
born into that's not something in our
control what we do with those things is
in our control
although the outcomes are not you know
you can try to be a great person to your
family and they can treat you like a
jerk you know or treat you as if you're
the adolescent that they remember from
20 years ago or whatever and likewise
you can make good good investments but
but lose out in the economy we can
choose quite a bit more I would say
today than than people in the past you
know especially since we have for
example the internet we're you know like
what we're doing right now is a matter
of our choices everybody who showed up
here chose to show up presumably because
they have some interest in character and
hepatitis and you know improving their
life that's the kind of thing but we do
have to recognize you know some
limitation so the other thing I would
say about that too is these are not
choices that we make once and for all
often times you know we get ourselves a
little breathing room by say breaking
off a toxic relationship and things get
better for a bit and then we realize oh
this isn't the only thing that I need to
work on in my life I have to you know
change this over here so yeah
mark has a good question here is
Epictetus advising us not to make value
judgments no not at all I mean we have
to make value judgments as a matter of
fact we can't avoid making any value
judgments whatsoever because if we did
we would we wouldn't desire or be averse
to anything and we do have to engage in
some actions it's a question of making
value judgments correctly and Epictetus
and the Stoics would say that most
people tend to get these things wrong
and if you know this is not something I
was talking about here but this is
something we could certainly get into
epictetus talks about the role of it
gets translated as contradiction but I
would say tension or would it be a
better way of translating the Greek term
is maje which means battle conflict
right when we talk about a person having
internal conflicts it's because their
value judgments and the emotions and
other things that stem from those are
not all harmonious with each other and
this is the way that we we start out you
know by the time that we start to study
stoic philosophy we are usually kind of
a mess and we make ourselves less and
less of a mess we're using you could say
we're using the prior ASIS to prune away
at parts of the pro races that are
screwed up we're using the rational
faculty to bear upon itself and to make
it more rational those are really the
same two two sides of the same coin so
it is very important to make value
judgments but to make them correctly and
stoic philosophy I think is a useful
guide for that although I wouldn't say
that you know it's supposed to be
followed slavishly you know you do see
some people in the stoic forms being
almost like fundamentalists you know
quoting chapter and verse and thinking
that proof text thing like that solves
everything no we're supposed to think
this through you know we're supposed to
you might say internal lines that make
it make it our own and you know and in
day after the circumstances that we find
ourselves in which which
very different than the culture that
Epictetus lived in and was shaped by so
we might you know discard some of it I
mean I have a beard so epictetus would
say I'm on the right track but do all
men need to have beards in order to look
like men I don't think so some of that
is culturally conditioned we'd get rid
of that sort of stuff but the core of it
I think is quite sound mmm there's a
good question from mark Oh any thought
about choice and character in connection
with a leadership role in business yeah
I think you know not just in business
but leadership roles this isn't
something I was talking about with one
of my clients who is in a leadership
role so it comes up an awful lot and
it's so easy to become corrupted in
leadership roles because you can have
people you know kind of justifying what
it is that you do right and so you
really have to be careful not to you
know make the wrong choices which then
become habits and start justifying
themselves I think that you know when an
organization functions well and not just
well for say it's stockholders but for
you know what we call it stakeholders
which would include its employees and
you know the outside community it's
going to often be because of good
leadership and good leadership is not
just you know getting people to do
things it's getting them to do the right
things in the right way you know
building the kinds of relationships
building a culture for example of trust
and accountability that runs all the way
from the bottom to the top so that the
people at the top are holding themselves
accountable and being treated as as
accountable that's kind of rare I think
these days particularly not just in
corporations but in academic
institutions as well that's that's a
real problem so let me scroll up a bit
because it looks like we've got a lot of
questions
appearin writes I know the weakness of
my character in the direction I need to
go to improve but I keep falling back
into being a slave to my desires how can
I keep the discipline for a longer
period well if it really is the case
where you're not making any progress in
like extending the amount of time
because you are you are going to fall
Epictetus you know says it's like
wrestling you know you're going to get
you're going to get knocked into the
dust and you got to get yourself up but
if you're really not finding that
there's any you know longer time between
the fall then I would say probably that
that's a sign that you need to look at
your thinking process and what's going
into you know the lead-up to the fall
you know because it's never just like
well I was you know doing great and then
boom you know suddenly I was at the
strip club or something like that
there's always some sort of story there
that you can analyze and I think you
know stoic philosophy can provide some
good resources for that but I don't I
don't know that you'd find all the stuff
that you would need in stoic philosophy
it often same thing with Aristotelian
virtue ethics it often works very well
in conjunction with psychotherapy and
other other resources for that we use to
modify our characters a manual can
somebody be a marketer and stoic at the
same time it depends on what kind of
marketer they're being you know if
they're being a marketer that says
anything goes and clearly not you know
if they're trying to do it in an ethical
way it'll probably involve turning away
some clients and not being quite as
world you know successful in a worldly
way then I don't see any any inherent
incompatibility for it so you know and
we could say similar things about other
other tasks as well you know so long as
is I mean you'd want to think in terms
of like the virtues as useful guide
particularly justice are you are you
going against any of the things that say
Cicero tells us or epictetus tells us
about how we ought to behave or Seneca
those would be useful guide guideposts
it is an interesting question this is a
bit of a digression but I'll say this
there's a lot of people who want to see
I think want their stoicism to fit some
something else you know that they're
really more interested in and because
they're attracted to stoicism and then
they're like yeah I'd also like to get
to do this 100% and often I mean this is
contained within epictetus we have to
decide which things we value more
because sooner or later they're going to
probably run into conflict with each
other and then then we've got to make a
decision that and that is part of how we
determine our our pro races these things
that we choose to sacrifice to each
other we don't usually get to have it
all at the same time John has a question
here a comparative question my thoughts
on Buddhist non-attachment
in relation to stoic indifference
preferred versus non preferred
indifference I don't really have too
many there's a good bit of discussion
out there doing comparative work about
Buddhism and stoicism and you know in
part because I used to teach you know
comparative religion and did a good bit
of research whenever somebody says
Buddhism I'm always like you know my
immediate instinct is saying okay which
Buddhism do you mean because there's a
lot of schools out there and they're not
all on the same page about everything I
mean there's sort of you could say
Common Core of texts but then they're
interpreted different ways I mean I
think there was actually a great piece
by one of one of the members of the
modern stoicism project Gregg Lopez last
year I think it was we published it and
it was it was discussing it wasn't
discussing not attachment it was
discussing
is you know stoic pearls okay the same
thing as Buddhist mindfulness and his
answer was no it's not it's something
that's similar in certain respects but
not the same thing and I think you know
taking a stab at this I would say it's
kind of a similar thing to that right we
can say that there there are some ways
in which it's it's similar but we want
to look at not just that single concept
but what role it plays within the larger
system because stoicism is a system the
net as one of my friends and colleagues
Travis Hume very you know you know
nicely framed it he talks about as a
sort of a network of concepts connected
with each other I think he's totally
right about that this is why it's hard
for me to answer the question about
Buddhism because you have different you
might say Buddhist networks depending on
which school were talking about so
there's my really good answer but it's
it's a I'll count it as an answer
nonetheless all right what other
questions if you guys get we're getting
close to the end if you don't have any
I'll jump ahead into the the final stuff
but if you do have any other questions
I'll hang around for a little bit over
time because I add my talking went a bit
over time my lecture part so I want to
make sure everyone has the opportunity
to ask whatever questions they want to
while people are thinking about any any
final ones let me tell you about some
useful Epictetus resources so I think
probably a lot of you know about my
videos there is a stoicism playlist
which is kind of cool and I'll have more
videos coming up in the month you know
in in 2018 but I think I've probably got
close to like 60 videos on epic penis
alone we also have this free epictetus
enchiridion course in the reason IO
Academy
it's just specifically on the end
karidian but it's got a lot of video
content and handouts cool stuff like
that so all you have to do with that is
type in reason IO Academy and you know
you'll find it and then we've got the
deeper dives online seminars on this
topic coming up on Saturday December
16th remember these are Central Time so
if you're in a different time zone you
want to make sure to get those those
times right so wrapping up the Q&A I'll
take this last set of questions from a
manual then why in certain parts of the
enchiridion does Epictetus advise not to
preach stoicism to others
I mean sharing the concepts a little bit
with others that have problems might be
useful for them sometimes yeah and I
think sharing sharing concepts with
others is not the same thing as
preaching solecism
epictetus is concerned about you know
this runs not just in the enchiridion
but really through that the discourses
the there were a lot of people back then
as today who would like adapt stoicism
as sort of the way people jump into
self-help programs now I'm a stoic you
know and they they'd hand internalized
it and that's that's not going to be
very productive
it never is for any approach you have to
spend some time with it internalizing it
practicing it before you should really
start talking about being in that that
group you know and it can actually
become quite an impediment you know when
people spend more time as he says like
you know arguing about what cruciferous
is saying and less about applying it but
but Epictetus doesn't think that that
precludes you from actually you know
sharing stoicism with people when
they're receptive to it but you saying
listen if you're not actually walking
the walk it's not going to hurt stoicism
because stoicism is just a set of
concepts but people are going to laugh
at you because you're not going to be
able to pull it off and that's not going
to be good for you that's not going to
be helpful in your progress Jon has a
question the best way to follow me
Twitter I do have a Twitter account
it's philosopher seventy I mean if you
just type in Gregory Sadler all sorts of
things will pop up my facebook page you
know our I think our reason IO Academy
my YouTube channel there's there's a lot
of things the the social media that I
use the most are Facebook Twitter
Google+ and LinkedIn occasionally I'm on
reddit but I don't really I don't really
like the forum don't do too much with
that and that of course you know YouTube
has a social function again so all right
let me one more time thank my patreon
supporters for you know generously
contributing to my earning and income
doing this sort of thing which is what
allows me to be able to provide these
these free webinars and let me go back
to the the wrap up any other quick
questions to get in under the wire
before we conclude this this webinar all
right well I will say have a great day
those of you who are on the other side
of the Atlantic have a great evening and
those of you here in this Hemisphere
have a great morning or afternoon
whatever it happens to be depending on
what time zone you're in and we'll have
more of these coming up and we'll have
the online seminars coming up this
Saturday great questions and I very much
enjoyed this